meet Jordan shlonsky he's worked for me
for over 20 years and I still have no
idea what he does on the show
Jordan quick question what are your
responsibilities on this show I have
various duties my title is Associate
Producer it's the greatest mountain
answer I've ever heard various
production related tasks if used the
word various one more time I'm having
you arrested what do you do when you
come into work varies from time on top
of that Jordan has spent all of the
money I've been paying him on over 30
that's right 30 lavish trips to Italy
making him a self-proclaimed expert on
all things Italian this is a free
biscotti yes this go to Putney it's a
piece go to biscotti that would be if
there was more than one there's only one
feel the combination of textures between
the gelato and the torchy no feel the
combination of temperatures between the
hot and the cold
you know God davidon come here mouth you
know cartouche up against my better
judgment I finally decided to experience
Italy through Jordans cold dead eyes by
tagging along with him on the exact same
route he always takes like a migrating
anal-retentive swallow Jordan begins his
solo journey in Florence then travels
south through Tuscany stopping in the
tiny hill town of Cortona before winding
up in the city of Naples
this is Conan and Jordan in it
first stop on the jordan tour the
streets of florence that's an absolutely
gorgeous morning the quality of Sun here
in Florence is invigorating you act like
oh we're in Italy we're in Florence
sunlight is warm here there's warm
sunlight every some way it is by its
nature warmth don't get me wrong
I love being in Florence I just think
you overdo it sometimes I think you're
sensing things it may not exist and
notice the texture of the clouds this is
something we don't get it home and look
at the level within the atmosphere what
are you a pilot now
when I travel I like to connect with the
place tangibly and I like to touch
adventure surfaces and remember what
they felt like if I touch this stone
there's a rub on that stone close and
prized yeah and notice the coldness of
the stone and the texture of the stone
this guy's perving out on a wall
everybody I could tell you exactly what
the base of the Roman Colosseum feels
like I can tell you oh you rubbed up
against the Gaussian teller bet you
haven't bet you've left a little DNA at
every crime scene you're like we could
take a photo here why would you want a
photo with anybody else in it
you only take photos by yourself cuz you
only have one expression you have a mask
you always look exactly the same in your
photographs you look like you're chasing
after Keanu Reeves in the matrix say mr.
Anderson you disappoint me put a down
jacket on the dachshund that's what I
like
because women just enjoying her de la
dolce vita buongiorno rigatoni circling
speaking the small penis was considered
advantageous and a thing of beauty it's
only in modern times that the larger
penis has been generally favored yes
Oh for a time machine once you'll ever
know limoncello there's what I like to
do yeah what I'm walking around I like
to yell out random Italian things right
no Magna look thee it just makes it look
like I say that's not a pasta I think
that it says sometimes considered to be
insulting now when you yell I don't
think it's considered in fake Italian
word know-it-all clearly as an American
not at all
you keep thinking it's offensive people
just think that I'm Italian
I go in a Ken Jimmy pesto pesto
see I said pasta with him and he said
pesto back that doesn't mean he's
offended know who Siri
oh look well that is Pinocchio this is
absolutely fantastic if I purchase this
would you be willing to walk around in
this oh well here great big office I
swear I'll pay you extra money okay this
is your sandwich right wanna come join
us
no it's like this try again well they
hate you
mother Oh
you see that's barbaric we are now part
of the history of Florence we are right
there with Michelangelo and Dante this
is your contribution this is your moment
the floods
[Applause]
[Music]
you